Bloomberg News reporter Madeleine
McMahon identified one area in
particular where women are sorely
underrepresented we talked we talked
about this earlier in the program
private equity specifically women can
comprise just less than 11 percent of
senior managers in private equity
Blackstone has the greatest percentage
of high ranking women managers at nearly
16 percent Madeline joins us now with
more on her story and speaking about
Blackstone you know Steve Schwarzman as
I mentioned just put in place this new
maternity leave policy extending it I
believe from 12 weeks now to 16 weeks
for his female employee so that's you
know one step in the right direction but
private equity is it is terribly behind
right
other sectors in terms of employing
high-level women yeah so what we found
is that while banking has about 16%
women senior management private equity
only has about 10% on average so that's
substantially below and there are a few
reasons for that I mean private equity
firms primarily recruit from banks so
because that percentage is dropping
there's something happening at the
recruitment level where not enough women
are actually even applying for these
jobs so right so there's a dearth of
talent then that they find not
necessarily aiders of talent I mean the
problem is that what these firms are
trying to do on the recruitment level is
try and find more women to apply to
their jobs so like you were mentioning
with Steve Schwarzman
and Blackstone there's two different
facets of how firms are identifying
bringing more women into their workforce
so one is at the entry level and there's
a few different initiatives for that
some firms are trying to find women who
will intern with them and yeah during
the undergraduate level so bringing them
on oh really right exactly when the
second thing the second component is
retention and that's something that is
not so specific to private equity
because really a lot of businesses have
this issue as well but maternity leave
is a great start and that policy has
been I think really well received and
people are looking towards that to
expand it even more and thus you see
that from front from from Steve
Schwarzman and Blackstone
yeah which seems to be the more
progressive of some of the firms then
you profiled several women though who
basically said you know I'm never gonna
reach the top I'm gonna strike out on my
own right
and have they done they've done really
well I mean we're seeing that trend kind
of increasing there are some firms where
women are the fund managers and those
are rare but something that's great
about those is there are these female
role models who are founders of the firm
or who are the bear demon deal makers
and they're able to bring in more women
at the lower level saying look I did
this you can do all right
Madeline thank you so much bringing that
story for us really eye-opening here
Madeline McMann of Bloomberg News